[Music]
we've seen Veronica Lodge get plenty of
action on Riverdale just trust me she
was how strong we are together and now
it seems actress Camilla Mendez has
found love in her real life too the 24
year old brunette beauty got candid with
nylon magazine about dating she coyly
revealed she is seeing someone and he's
not a fellow actor quote it's somebody
completely out of the industry dating
people in the industry is tough it's
hard when that's your world cami
admitted she's dated actors in the past
which she says was really tough quote
actors are really emotionally
complicated I just really need to get
out of this industry with someone who's
in a stable environment so who is the
man that stole Camilla's heart fans seem
to think it's Victor Houston who posted
these selfies with cute captions like
happy birthday beautiful and baby one
thing's for sure
whomever Camilla dates he needs her
on-screen dad Mark Consuelos is seal of
approval
mark is like my actual dad in that way /
he's like very protective I have to get
his seal of approval he's just an
all-around good guy yeah manners
gentlemen like the first thing he said
about one guy he was like very polite
very polite
[Music]
[Applause]